يبدو ان الدول المشاركه في كاس العالم
2022 9 جاهده لظهور بشكل متميز على صعيد
التشجيع حيث تعمل عده بلدان مشاركه في
العرس العالمي لمنع المشجعين المتعصبين من
الوصول الى قطر المستضيفه للممتعه
الارجنتين وبريطانيا كانت على راس الدول
في منع المشجعين المتورطين في اعمال عن في
بلادهم الحضور كاس العالم حيث اعلنت
الجهات الامنيه في ميونخ منع سته الاف
مشجع من الذهاب لقطر مؤكده انها تريد
اعاده السلام كره القدم
1300 مشجع من ذوي الخطر ممنوعين من الذهاب
لحضور مباريات كاس العالم حيث اكدت سلطات
البريطانيه وانها لن تسمح بتشويه البطوله
العالميه
[موسيقى]
نورنا في الاستوديو زماننا العزيز مراسل
صباح العربيه في روسيا والمهتم بكره القدم
عبد الجواد الرشد عبد الجواد يسعد صباحك
يعني تعودنا على كل الاونه الاخيره كان
مراسل يغطي الحروب
لمعلومات كره القدم
فيك في الصوديوم صباح العربيه وهنا في دبي
اولا وبدي احكي للمشاهدين انه عبد الجواد
متحدى الزملاء وكل العالم انه يعني انه ما
يكون في معلومه ناقصه بهذا الكتاب وهذا
التحدي سعره 1500 دولار بس عشان نخبر
العالم يعني هذا بدل قد ايه عبد الجواز
كاتب بشكل كامل الكتاب سنوات من العمل
الطويل طبعا مع الزميل الاستاذ محمود
قرقوره من سوريا ومقرشف ضمن اللجنه الفيفا
وهو قادر يعني على ذكر اي معلومات يعني
عمل ليل نهار همم
حاضر
المشاغبين في كره القدم
والحل الوحيد
للفيفا كان يعني هو في خاص قرارات
الجميع يتذكر طبعا ما فعلت جماهير
الارجنتين بدءا من بدايه البطوله في عام
1930 من القرن الماضي يعني بعد ان خسر
المباراه النهائيه قاموا بتحطيم مبنى
السفاره الارجوانيه في بونس اريس طبعا في
حتى في الظلم المشجعين الخطرين يطال ايضا
سفارات بلادها يا طال اتحاد كره القدم في
بلادها في حال لم يتاهل منتخبنا نحو
المونديال كما حدث في 38 حتى في 86 عندما
فازت الارجنتين بقلقب كاس العالم لم
يخرجوا دون مشاكل وقاموا باصطياد المشجعين
الانجليز وتكسير وتحطيم الكثير يعني هي
موجه كبيره تشتتاح ملاعب كره القدم
الاجواء المحبه وكره القدم يعني في فهي
رياضه السلام رقم واحد لكن من دون
المشاحنات لا يمكن تشاهدي او تتابعي
مباراه لكره القدم
فيما يتعلق بالرياضه التعصب الكره في هذا
الحديث راح نحكي مع المحل الرياضي محمود
ماهر الذي الينا الان استاذ محمود ده يسعد
هالصباح قرار الجريء اليوم انه نحكي عن
دول عاشقه لكره القدم وانه تحد من الجمهور
والحضور الى المونديال بسبب هذا التعصب ما
رايك بهذا القرار اولا
طبعا قرار
رائع جدا من الدول زي انجلترا وزي
[موسيقى]
قطر كمان انها تكون متعاونه مع بريطانيا
ومع الارجنتين مع جميع الدول المشاركه في
كاس العالم لان هناك يعني جماهير متعصبه
جدا في في كاس العالم بصفه مستمره همم من
ضمنها مثلا جماهير بولندا يعني من زمان
حتى استاذ عبد الجواد وهو بيتكلم همم من
من السبعينات او من الستينات بدات لما
ظهرت تتفشها اكثر في كاس العالم على وجه
التحديد همم الدول المنظمه لكاس العالم
بتدعوا ان بعض المنتخبات لا تتاهل لكاس
العالم
وجود همم
البلاد زي همم انجلترا زي همم بولندا
الارجنتين وتكلمته كثير عن الارجنتين ان
هم منعوا 3000 مشجع
ودي مش اول مره تحصل لان هم يمنعوا مشجعين
حصلت قبل كده في مونديال روسيا همم اتمنع
مشجعين من انجلترا ومشجعين من بولندا
ومشجعين من الارجنتين عدد كبير جدا حتى في
كاس العالم في جنوب افريقيا اتمنع نفس
العدد تقريبا دايما يتمنع مشجعين قبل كاس
العالم
هل هذا صحيح هل يمكن تبرير الشغب في هذه
الحاله
طبعا غير مبرر لكن همم الشغب بيحدث
بالاسباب اسباب احيانا سياسيه اسباب انه
همم لا يوجد ضغط في الشارع يوجد حريه
مخرطه همم بالنسبه للجماهير همم يعني في
انتشار مثلا المواد الكحوليه وده همم مش
هيحصل فيه قطر ممكن نشوف المره دي مونديال
مسلم جدا في الشارع غير كل مره يعني في
كاس العالم في في في في مارسيليا سنه 98
حصلت كوارث يعني ولعوا في مارسيليا
الجماهير الانجليزي بسبب افرتهم في الكحول
حتى اساطير الانجليز لنفسهم بيفرضوا
الكحول زي بولس سكوين يعني همم اعتزل بسبب
ال ال الافراثه في الكحول لحد كده مات
بسبب الكحول استاذ محمود انضم لنا زميلنا
عبد الجواد كمان حابب يشارك
الجواد شو بتحب تسال كمان او بتعطي مداخله
مرحبا محمود
جدا بيختفي عن الناس في البدايه طبعا
بتعرف انت مباراه القمه بالدوري
الارجنتيني قبل يومين شهد الطرد 10 لاعبين
والجمهور اتصرف بطريقه جدا غريبه لكن بدي
اسالك سؤال وجوابه جدا يكون صريح رغم كل
القوانين التي تمنع دخول المشجعين
القاطرين المشجعين بلاقوا طريقه وبيلتفوا
حول هذا القانون وبيدخلوا الدول وبيحضروا
المباريات وبيكونوا بجانب الملعب صحيح ولا
لا صحيح صحيح بيلاقوا حلول لانه بيتم منع
الجماهير قبل 10 ايام من من مونديال بيسحب
يعني بيتم ايقاف الباسوردات من قبل
المونديال ب 10 ايام 10 ايام لكن الجماهير
ممكن تخرج قبل ال 10 ايام من البلد في
انجلترا مثلا ممكن يخرجوا ويحضروا عن طريق
الدخول من بلد اخرى محيطه بقطر زي
الامارات او زي مصر اي دوله خليجيه اخرى
هلا هو معروف في العالم انه دستور الفيفا
من اقوى الدساتير وصححني ان كنت مخطئه يا
عبد الجواد طب في هذه الحاله هل ممكن
بالمستقبل نشوف مثلا انه قانون في دستور
الفيفا انه بكل مونديال او كل مباريات
عالميه راح تصير انه ممنوع دخول المتعصمين
هذا يجي من الفيفا دغري مش من الدول معقول
هيك السؤال لكم الاثنين يعني تفضل يا
محمود
لكن لكن لكنه لسه ما وصلش لدرجه مثلا
الدوري الانجليزي الدوري الانجليزي موجود
دستور اقوى من كده انه بيتم منع المشجع ان
هو يحضر كاس العالم مباريات المحليه لمده
لمده زمنيه كبيره ممكن خمس توصل لخمس سنين
حصلت كثير جدا حوادث بسبب العنصريه بسبب
همم اقتحام الارض الملعب وهكذا لكن في
الفيفا لسه لغايه دلوقت مطبقش القوانين
القويه اللي هي موجوده في الدوري
الانجليزي همم ان هو يمنع مشجع مثلا كاس
العالم لمده 10 سنين
شكرا جزيلا لمرحله الرياضي محمود ماهر
وقبل ما خلص معك عبد الجواد انت من
المشجعين متعصبين شوف فريقك في المنطقه
ههه لا شكرا جزيلا